peut-être qu'on a un travail qui est
moins physique
qu'auparavant mais maintenant c'est ce
que je disais ce matin en discutant avec
les collègues c'est on travaille nous
dans les lignes à la lumière et à la
solette et au bruit
quoi ce
stressous conditionne et on a toujours
l'impression parce que c'est promesses
CLI c'est c'est ça toujours l'impression
comme on disait ce matin déjà dès que tu
emboues tu te sens la
Bour l'étude on va la faire sur la ligne
1 alors donc pour répondre à V question
on a choisi la ligne 1 pourquoi c'est
aujourd'hui c'est la grosse activité de
c'est la vache allée de toopar c'est
l'quip de distribution en chiffre
d'affair c'est 50 % du chiffre d'affair
pour nous c'est la plus grosse activité
quoi d'accord sachant qu'historiquement
on en a parlé avec l'infirmière
effectivement les les les problèmes de
de tendinite ils sont apparus là en
quelques cas qu'on a eu ils sont apparus
sur cette ligne on a eu l'occasion de
faire une expérience avec Michel
merit au niveau de l'automobile sur un
point particulier et qui a vraiment bien
porter ses fruits parce que il s'intègre
systématiquement tout l'environnement il
y a pas que l'ergonomie par elle-même
mais tout l'environnement l'organisation
l'observation des gens la prise en
compte de l'opinion des gens enfin tout
ce qui vraiment